das war natürlich eine richtige Klatsche
für die Ampel aber vor allem für den
Politikstil für die Arroganz mit der man
mit diesem Thema umgeht maximale
Verunsicherung geschaffen dann dieses
Projekt mehrmals verändert neu
geschrieben und dann letzte Woche am
Freitag
110 Seiten quasi komplett anderes Gesetz
vorlegen und dem Bundestag darüber nicht
mehr beraten lassen wollen und wenn man
schon eingesteht dass da eine hohe
Verunsicherung in der Bevölkerung da ist
die auch übrigens nach wie vor da ist
die übrigens auch erstmal bleiben wird
weil eben die wärmeplanung des Gesetz
kommt erst im Herbst weil die
Förderrichtlinie die soll erst im Herbst
kommen das schafft jetzt wieder
Verunsicherung weiß einfach nicht auf
dem Tisch liegt und jetzt in dieser
Phase dann zu glauben man könnte so ein
Gesetz was in Wahrheit niemand versteht
bisher und der Bundestag nicht beraten
kann dadurch zu peitschen das ist diese
Arroganz die kritis